Hello and welcome to this video where we will be jumping into the engine and starting off
some of our exercises.
Before we start there is a project file which comes with this course.
I highly recommend that you download it.
This course is designed to be a follow along and this really helps to make sure that you
know how to set everything up and have some hands on experience working with it.
Now there are a few plugins that you might want to have turned on or who are actually
required some of them if you want to use smart objects.
In the project that we are downloading these plugins should already be turned on so you
don't need to worry about setting them up and restarting them but I would like to go
over them here.
So to start off with we have the smart object plugin and this is what will allow us to set
up and use the smart objects.
The second one is the AI behavior.
Now the smart object system doesn't necessarily use the AI behavior system but it is recommended
and this is the system that we are going to be using in all of our examples.
It is a modular way of creating behaviors that can be plugged into things like state
trees.
And in order to get these running in combination with each other there is another plugin that
we are likely to turn on and that's the gameplay behavior smart objects.
Now these two systems to talk to each other.
Now we are going to use another plugin which again is not necessary but it does really
help when you are trying to tie together animations with specific locations and measures.
And that plugin is motion warping.
What this is going to allow us to do is adjust animations dynamically so that we can have
things like sitting, vaulting and interacting can line up correctly with the smart objects
and the measures that are within the level.
Now with that said let's jump into the project and we will start off by creating the classes
that are going to be needed.
Now when you've downloaded this project and opened it up you should hopefully get a screen
that looks a little bit like this.
Now we are using something that is called the trained and paid and what this is going
to allow us to do is it's going to allow us to move between the different sections of
the project as we are going through and it's going to highlight the assets that we are
going to want to be used.
So hopefully this fires up a new start up.
If not under the links first kill this town under the link selection we have the training
paid and that will bring this up.
What I usually recommend is that you take it and you dock it in the top here and ideally
place the heartline below it and if you bring it down so you can just see the top you can
check that you are on the same slide as me and we are in the correct place to teach the
class.
If you don't have it don't worry too much the level itself isn't too hard to navigate.
I am going to jump to the first slide here the example chairs.
One thing you can see is this is brought on my content browser and we are going to be
doing a lot of work in the content browser so I am going to hit the button dock in layout.
Now you can see that we have it down here.
We are at the exercise one and we can see that we have our files that we are going to
be looking at.
Now at the moment we have one NPC who is in the level if you had a push play he would
do nothing.
Well this is because we have some problems in our state tree and if we have a look at
our state tree chair and I was doing that up as you can see we have a relatively simple
state tree and what it is going to do is we have a root and we have seen if we can find
a smart object that is unclaimed and we use that smart object if we can find it.
Now if we do not find the smart object we are going to come down to the part of combat
here and wander about and go back to root and after we have come back to root we are
going to check to see if we have a smart object again.
So it is a straight forward we have two settings we are wandering around with using a smart
object.
Now the reason why this is not working is because if we really jump into the tasks you
would see that we are lacking a load of code and that is because we are going to add in
this code as part of the exercise so that we can see how it is working.
But before we do that we are going to need to create a few different classes.
So the first class that I would like you to make is gameplay behave.
So this is what we are going to run when we actually go in and use the object.
So I am going to come up in here I am going to search for blueprint class and I am going
to search for gameplay behavior and you can see that we have gained by behavior here.
And I will select that and I am going to name this GB for gameplay behavior and sitting
down.
So we are going to be doing a lot of sitting down.
Okay so that is my first class.
Now the next class that I want is going to be the gameplay behavior config.
If you right hand click again come up to the blueprint class and search for gameplay behavior
config.
See that we have that here and it is a behavior config and we will open that up.
And it goes gameplay and I will rename this GBC under store for sitting down.
So I have gained by behavior config.
So again the gameplay behavior is the actual thing that we are going to do.
The config is the configuration where we can change some of the settings in the gameplay
behavior.
Now the next thing we are going to do is create a smart object definition.
Now this is slightly different to how we have created the other ones because what we are
actually going to do is right hand click and we are going to be looking into the miscellaneous
side.
And from this we are going to be selecting a data asset because this is what the definition
is going to be part of.
So if I search for smart you can see that we have an option for a smart object definition.
I am going to select that and I am going to call this smart object definition so sod
and this is going to be for a chair.
I am just going to call that sod chair.
Now we have all the files we need in the next video where we can start setting them up so
that they work in conjunction with each other.